Thank You Ted all right it's time for
this week's pet project let's welcome in
Amy Lee she's joining us from the in
SPCA hey I know you brought somebody
special along who needs a safe and good
homes Alessio this handsome guy is the
best two and a half year old boy and he
is looking for a great home I love that
and tell us how you guys are dealing
with adoptions and you know the changes
with cope in nineteen so the building is
closed to the public but we are taking
people in by appointment only and we're
actually also doing adoptions over at
Petsmart so that's a great day of Monday
through Saturday from 10:00 to 2:00 with
us with cats and then on the weekends on
Fridays and Saturdays we have dogs and
kittens when they're available Jackson
is a case where we would have an
appointment and the potential adopter
would come here to the shelter attorney
Burton because we need to find the right
home for him he's a lot of energy he
needs a lot of exercise but he's such a
good boy and is so receptive to training
definitely every animal is special and
needs its own little special treatment
but of course we want to ask after
fourth of July
were there any lost dogs coming in or
what was the effect on on the in SPCA
after fourth of July absolutely so we
try to be as preventative as we can we
tell people look you got to keep your
dogs inside you got to keep them feeling
safe it's dangerous out there and they
get scared they run away yeah lost dogs
go to the Animal Foundation and
hopefully they're their owners will
claim them from from the Animal
Foundation oftentimes with the animals
not claimed after their hold do will
help the Animal Foundation and take some
of their dogs here you don't know and
let's talk about just you know in
general what you guys offer at the end
SPCA for people wondering what they can
adopt from you guys absolutely so if you
check out our website all the cats we
have a lot of wonderful cats looking for
homes the cats are actually Pet Smart
will stay at Petsmart next to their name
so you we try to give you a little bio
about their their behavior and just as
much as we know about them and then same
with the dogs you know you just check
the website often and keep it updated
check our social media we try to keep
you as up-to-date as possible all right
thank you so much Amy and thank you back
in adopting a pet go to the Nevada n
SPCA
or excuse me in SPCA org or call them at
7:02 eight seven three seven seven two
to Las Vegas now we'll be right back